this episode has been supported by lamda
dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here I can
confidently say that this is the most
excited I've been for a smoke simulation
paper since wavelet turbulence wavelet
turbulence is a magical algorithm from
2008 that takes a low quality fluid or
smoke simulation and increases its
quality by filling in the remaining
details and here we are 11 years later
the results still hold up insanity this
is one of the best papers ever written
and has significantly contributed to my
decision to pursue a research career and
this new work performs style transfer
for smoke simulations if you haven't
fallen out of your chair yet let me try
to explain why this is amazing star
transfer is a technique in machine
learning research where we have two
input images one for content and one for
style and the output is our content
image re-imagined with this new style
the cool part is that the content can be
a photo straight from our camera and the
style can be a painting which leads to
the Superfund results that you see here
an earlier paper had shown that the more
sophisticated ones can make even art
curators think that they are real
however doing this for smoke simulations
is a big departure from 2d style
transfer because that one takes an image
where this works in 3d and does not deal
with images but with density fields the
density field means a collection of
members that describe how dense a smoke
plume is at a given spatial position it
is a physical description of a smoke
plume if you will so how could we
possibly apply artistic style from an
image to a collection of densities this
doesn't sound possible at all
unfortunately the problem gets even
worse since we typically don't just want
to look at a still image of a smoke
plume but enjoy a physically correct
simulation not only the density fields
but the velocity fields and the forces
that animate them over time also have to
be stylized again that's either
impossible or almost impossible to do
you see if we ran a proper smoke
simulation we'll see
what would happen in reality but that's
not stylized however if we stylize we
get something that would not happen in
mother nature I have spent my master's
thesis trying to solve a problem called
fluid control which would try to coerce
a smoke plume or a piece of fluid to
take a given shape like a bunny or a
logo with letters you can see some
footage of what I came up with here here
both the simulation and the controlling
force field is computed in real time on
the graphics card and as you see it can
be combined with wavelet turbulence if
you wish to hear more about this work
make sure to leave a comment but in any
case I had a wonderful time working on
it if anyone wants to pick it up the
paper in the source code and even a
blender add-on version are available in
the video description in any case in a
physics simulation we are trying to
simulate reality and for style transfer
we are trying to depart from reality the
two are fundamentally incompatible and
we have to reconcile them in a way that
is somehow still believable super
challenging however back then when I
wrote the fluid control paper learning
based algorithms were not nearly as
developed so it turns out they can help
us perform style transfer for density
fields and also animate them properly
again the problem definition is very
easy in comes a smoke plume we had an
image for style and the style of this
image is somehow applied to the density
field to get these incredible effects
just look at these marvelous results
fire textures starry night you name it
it seems to be able to do anything one
of the key ideas is that even though
style transfer is challenging on highly
detailed density fields it becomes much
easier if we first down sample the
density field to a coarser version
perform the star transfer there and up
sample this density field again with
already existing techniques rinse and
repeat the paper also describes a
smoothing technique that ensures
the changes in the velocity fields that
guide our density fields changed slowly
over time to keep the animation
believable there are a lot more new
ideas in the paper so make sure to have
a look it also takes a while the
computation time is typically around 10
to 15 minutes per frame but who cares
today with the ingenuity of research
scientists and the power of machine
learning algorithms even the impossible
seems possible if it takes 15 minutes
per frame so be it what a time to be
alive if you're a researcher or startup
looking for cheap GPU compute to run
these algorithms check out lambda GPU
cloud I've talked about lambdas GPU
workstations in other videos and I'm
happy to tell you that they are offering
GPU cloud services as well the lambda
GPU cloud can train imagenet to 93%
accuracy for less than $19 lambdas
web-based IDE
lets you easily access your instance
right in your browser and finally hold
on to your papers because the lambda GPU
cloud costs less than half of AWS and
aja make sure to go to lambda labs comm
slash papers and sign up for one of
their amazing GPU instances today thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time